[Music]
this episode is sponsored by google play
with the help of candy crush saga
hey party people how's it going welcome
to another exciting episode of honest
trailer commentaries the show where we
talk about our honest trailer for this
week toy story 4.
give your behind-the-scenes thoughts go
into a little more depth we watch the
trailer together we see some cut
jokes deleted scenes and we answer
comments and questions from viewers like
you
so keep them coming on that side of the
screen i hope i got that right
uh and then we teased next week's honest
trailer hey lon how's it going
hey how's it going taco's here he
sometimes i start talking and he thinks
i'm talking to him and he freaks out and
this is easier
than him sitting back there howling much
better and
and i will now soothe him by thanking
our sponsor one more time because this
episode has got brought to you by google
play
click the link in the description that
way to satisfy your gaming sweet tooth
with candy crush saga
and download now i'm a candy car saga
player a lot i didn't know if you knew
that
oh wow i liked it so much i'm also a
member
are you in the thousands at this point
the hundreds
i don't know it goes on forever i just
like to watch the little bleep loops
bloop away it's very satisfying
um but we're here today to talk today
about toy story 4.
um it goes without saying that it's a
good movie but i think you have to judge
it against the
other toy stories and in that sense it's
maybe my least favorite toy story
what say you huh i feel like the first
one i mean
you gotta you gotta give it up to the
first toy story for being
what it was this sort of groundbreaking
moment in animation
a great movie i'm not here to knock it
but i think it's probably the one on
rewatch that i'm the least inclined to
revisit
just because it's the most outdated
animation now and it's the most you know
it's a it's a basic sort of story
compared to
what the franchise would do in later
times so i'm not i'm not sure i'd have
to go back and like
review the whole franchise but i'm
inclined to say that's probably my least
favorite
i agree with this one is a uh that
basicness of toy story one
is what appeals to me the most though
lon and i feel like it's
there's been kind of toy story inflation
where they've added more
uh plot points and more razzle dazzle to
it whereas the first one was such just
an elemental story
about growing up and moving on and they
kind of keep having to like
yeah that's why i think two is the best
because to me two is the perfect balance
of
it's still this very sort of sweet story
that's
focused on the the few sort of main
characters
and it expands the universe in a way
that still feels true to what the first
movie was doing
but it makes it on like a grander scale
and you're outside and it's in the world
more uh i feel like three is when it
started to get so
weighty like i first became aware of
like
wow this is like existential and like
it's really
emotional and then four i think that
almost reaches
it's almost ridiculous and for how uh
you know sad it is in some ways how
reflective and how like
it's got this real melancholy that it
didn't have
at first i i think that was always
subtext i think even in the first one
from the idea of uh of you not having a
purpose anymore was there but now it's
become the super text
they just uh it was like super liminal
advertising
yeah it was like bittersweet in one and
two but there was still it was like a
whimsical
story that just had this kind of edge to
it whereas three and four i think is
where it's becoming like the text like
these are sad depressing tales about
obsolete
objects that recognize their
obsolescence and i think that that was
uh um that was handled as well as you
could hope for
in three and it gave them like a good
send-off and every time they announced a
new toy story i would say why
but then every time they had an answer
until this one i think that's why it's
my least favorite because i just don't
feel like it was necessary
character-wise or necessarily was saying
anything new
about these characters that they managed
to do in one two and three
yeah i mean i think that's i think
that's partly true and i also think that
it
like in in a lot of ways this one is
just starting to show like
maybe that this premise is now expanded
beyond its cell by date i mean it also
feels like
fair and antique store right across the
way from each other like we're just
running out of primary locations
like places for there to reasonably be
toys we're like
running up against how many more of
these movies do we have like i was
like i think i pitched this and we
didn't include it in the honest trailer
like i guess there's a guy's cubicle
might have
toys and like a sex shop has
toys like we're almost at i don't know
where else we go i think that the the
the problem is
you go with contemporary toys and
they're all
on a phone and then you're just doing uh
ralph breaks the internet
right uh yeah and i mean it's just like
just just real world locations where
there are toys like what we've done at
school
we've done a daycare we've done you know
like we're just
kids don't bring their toys that many
places you guys i mean really it
shouldn't have
a room in a fast food place if they had
the guts they'd do
it since toys are sentient you know
they'd have some type of
liberation where they go assault the
factories where they're assembled
and wow yeah i like to do a small
soldiers type turning on their masters
boots boots riley does a toy story yeah
i mean give toy story five to boots
right
finally give toy story to boots riley is
what we're saying
anyways we'll get into more of it as we
now watch the honest trailer for toy
story 4.
hit it
[Music]
from one of your favorite disney plus
categories comes a whimsical adventure
about how sometimes daddies feel useless
and when daddies feel useless it's bye
bye kids
and hello nurse toy story 4.
i just character wise i feel like this
can't be the first time i know it was in
one and i think it was in
two and three to some extent is like
it's so much about
propping up woody's fragile ego like
that just keeps having to happen
again and again and again yeah yeah well
it's i
here's the thing and i think i also
wrote a whole big thing this did sort of
make it into the honest trailer
i think this movie for the first time is
really pushing up against
like the what is the nature of the toy
owner relationship and like
is it weirdly one side like are toys
happy slaves
in this in this world they're like it's
gonna see because we assume in what
right it is
sort of like the droid and star wars
problem where we assume in the first one
it's like well but that's the ultimate
goal if you're a toy that's what's most
fulfilling for you
is to play with the child that owns you
would bring that kind of happiness like
that's your goal in life it'd be like a
human who would get very skilled at
something when you do your work and then
somebody
gets a lot of benefit out of it that's
satisfaction and i feel like that worked
in the first movie is like the metaphor
but by now where it's like oh woody
really would be happy going off on his
own and being with his love
beau peep but he feels this like weird
duty to his owner and it's like we're
not really exploring that tension and
it's uncomfortable like i don't know if
they have a good
i don't know if they have a good answer
for that like well does a toy have a
responsibility like
just because a kid owns you and like you
can
and we see how randomly ownership of
toys can work it's like literally if a
kid sees you in a box and is like
oh a dolly it's like is that a lifelong
contract now that you've entered into
like it seems highly neurotic this is
maybe why woody is such a mess it's just
the day-to-day
existence of being a toy is like
constantly doing these like special ops
missions to like recover lost comrades
and to like be
ready to play dead at the drop of a hat
and stuff like that always looking over
your shoulder for you
it sounds terrible it's like yeah it's
like why
like they're not getting they're not
getting compensated
it's not a job i was thinking of it in
the first toy story the metaphor of like
a job like a job well done and it's
satisfying works
but by three or four it's like well no
this is just their their entire life is
like
sworn duty to these kids i just don't
know if the franchise is prepared to
really handle
all of this metaphorical weight we'll
we'll get into more of that later uh uh
keep playing yeah
rejoin your old pals buzz and woody who
thanks to advancements in technology are
looking like they've had some work done
also rejoin no one else for very long to
make room for cool new merchandise
i mean characters like forky
pixar's attempt to make suicidal
depression fun for the whole family
you're just like
pause forky i mean
did he tread the annoying cute barrier
well enough for you or did he did he
fall to one side
i really i really liked forkey i think
in some ways because of what we're
pointing
out that it's so like almost wrong
in an animated movie like his his death
drive is so strong for the first half of
the movie
that you oh like it's it's shocking in
some ways like i thought it was really
funny i thought tony hale did a really
great
job but like i like that character a lot
i will say
um to sort of talk about what we what we
discussed at the beginning of this run
it does kind of bum me out now that
these movies are so much about every
time we've got to introduce this
new cast of new toy characters
voiced by all your favorite tv comedians
and like
we're doing that every time now and it's
it's just too much like
i don't feel like i've properly gotten
to know the toy story three gang
and now they're sidelined so i can meet
the toy story four gang and it's like
ah slow your roll like i just wanna
i just wanna hang out with wallace john
really yeah like rex and slinky dog are
still there like you don't need to keep
beefing up this ensemble so much it's
just going to get expensive for them too
like you really want to pay christy shaw
and jeff garland
and trump say two lines
yeah all right keen peel can't be cheap
these days but
yeah and i mean like that's it's great
it's fun to see them and christina
hendricks is at this one and like
they add cool new people every time i'm
not complaining but it is like
so aggressive now every time that it's
like we got to work 20 new toys into all
of these movies it's just like
okay then you're making it so each of
them gets like literally one throw away
line in the next movie and they're not
really a character anymore yeah i mean
they've kind of
they're not ensembles like this is about
buzz and woody and in this one really
just woody like they
not even but yeah i i i noticed that too
that buzz is almost
totally sidelined in this one and they
make him like a
he was never the brightest but they make
him like a stone cold idiot
in this in this movie um i i think it
takes a few steps
like just that he'd never even
considered like the nature of this voice
box that he's had forever
like you would have thought about what
that was before now right no
i mean it is a real thing that like you
need a new bit it's the fourth movie you
need a new bit for it
yeah people i was surprised to hear that
like people
don't have interior monologues like this
was like a debate
online like in your brain do you like
people don't hear
their own people right some people don't
well don't audibly hear
yeah yeah and can't and don't visually
picture things either that's that's the
like if if i say a chocolate ice cream
cone
some people actually visually in their
mind get an image of a chocolate ice
cream
whereas other people are just abstractly
conceptualizing
oh i know what that is uh so yeah all of
our brains are different
mine is just basically homer simpson
with the with the bear in the car
driving into the little monkey you know
the ballet
okay let's keep going you're just like
me
trash bunny and ducky an on-screen
depiction of how key and p will resent
being
chained to each other at this point in
their careers gabby gabby
the toy equivalent of cannibals who want
to harvest and consume body parts
to gain their enemies power but oh no
one wants to be her friend
and finally keanu reeves is here to be
keanu reeves
because someone said hey we've got
keanery's money so when the pot starts
to drag
let's cut to keanu reeves hey i didn't
know you could do that
can we just cash in on how much you love
keanu from other stuff too
kevin had too much fun making this one
yeah
uh surprise is keanu reeves
canadian he's not i i was just gonna ask
that like he can't be french-canadian
i mean he could but he doesn't sound
like he's a
french frenchman if you saw this film
without
context yeah be like oh they're making
fun of how that actor is
so canadian and like like it was just
weird like the whole character's bit is
canadian
but also canna reads but super canadian
but also
he's like he's not canadian like that's
a weird i totally i didn't even realize
it was keanu frankly until
afterwards um i thought they were just
making fun of you know
not super dave osborne but evel knievel
like this was a knock-off evil
evil toy yes it would have made sense if
it was like
mario lemieux i can't i can't even think
of like who are french canadian
celebrities celine dion uh
yeah there you go yeah yeah it's a
yeah it is canadian and apparently has
dual citizenship
and so by chat and chat is his law then
he is going to kiana reeves is canadian
wow there you go
he got it like quebecois like french
canadian people
he grew up he grew up in toronto so
there they are
they are correct he was born in beirut
but he grew up in toronto so he is
canadian wow so there you go that's
look i don't really know my canada but i
do feel like uh
you know a toronton making fun of french
canadians
is uh that's appropriation sir like
isn't
um get drake to do it all right keep
going
[Music]
it's working studios may have stopped
making dramas but that doesn't mean we
all don't still need a good crime now
and then
as you return to the franchise that
started out as a buddy comedy with the
dash of inside
but somehow along the way leaned hard
into existential dread
in this animated romp where the major
characters wonder if they have a soul
the voice inside of you who do you think
it is make snap decisions that will
determine their fate for the rest of
their lives
are you sure and confront the grim
reality of permanent physical injuries
that will render them garbage forever
wait so bobby lives in a position
there's like a particularly horrifying
moment where um
woody's like at that club at the antique
store like the nightclub or whatever
and this like battery operated toy goes
up to him it's like
battery i need a battery and it's played
like
like he's a junkie or like a junkie yeah
that's horrible battery-operated toys
are like
slowly dying and they need effects
with three and four they're finally like
okay everybody who saw the first one
when they were a kid
there they're adults now we can get
straight savage with this stuff like
we can just make this for the parents
and if the kid the kids will enjoy
bright colors shiny things whatever
they'll hear voices they know
uh but yeah this one feels like straight
up the middle for adults
and it's like sad and weird and like
yeah like forced people are agreeing to
donate their voice boxes so another toy
can get a new lease on life because they
were
broken from when they were born and it's
just like
my god are we gonna get to the fair
what's going on
when are we gonna get to the fireworks
factory isn't this a
this is a romp um
so yeah i mean i'm glad that it's less
like pixar formula like okay we can do
the drama and the weepy part and then
there's a chase seed and then there's
this
but like it is it's a bit much in this
one like it's really dark
yeah um i do think well we'll talk about
the pixar formula uh and chase scenes
shortly or we can just get to it now
where it's like i think that they
they usually do such a good job of
balancing character
and theme and action um uh
so artfully that like you don't even
notice but this one it seemed like very
contrived and like kind of mcguffin
to just get woody from a to b to c to d
to e to f and then they'd just have like
little dark modes along the way
i mean that is kind of what i'm saying
about it's the
i think the the the antique store and
the fair
stuff it's just like i know these are
two locations you really wanted to use
but there's just a lot of like business
about them that feels like
extraneous like we got to get here and
then you got to get in here and through
here and to here and we do do this bit
it's coming up in the trailer where it's
like like it used to be
the whole movie would be one relatively
simple
mission like a human it would be
something that would take us a minute
like
i got to go from this house over to next
door upstairs
you know like it's that uh oh i'm
trapped in the car i gotta get back home
but now it was very rise of skywalkery
we're like we gotta find the triangle to
find the doodad that helps us to find
the other triangle to see where the guy
is sitting right and it's always like a
three-part
three-step thing and before we get here
we gotta do this and then this
we need to split up so you can have a b
yeah
yeah a little a little bit a lot of just
like business and i think he and peel
are funny in this but their characters
and that whole scenario i think
a lot of it is just like all right i
mean obviously we gotta get
buzzed through this fairground somehow
uh you know via comical business
insert comical business here yeah i mean
but it is like
and and and they don't have a choice so
there's nothing else they're gonna make
they're not gonna make this a terrence
malik movie
but it does at this point it's been a
formula long enough that you do feel the
movie falling into that mode it's like
okay heart tugging reunion
here okay you know set up for a new
character here
okay you know like yeah it's this chunk
and then this chunk and then this chunk
and then you're done yeah
all right keep going wait so bobby lives
on a playground and she's made of
porcelain but the only thing that's
broken in years is one arm
i'm starting to think these movies
aren't even based on a true story
right along for another story about some
toys where they're not even trying to
hide their sentience anymore
your backpacks are the antique stores
and who will turn against their masters
if it furthers their selfish aims
dad's totally going to jail because
that whole ending where like they make a
rv plow through a carnival like
it is a miracle that there aren't
children stuck in that wheel well at the
end of toy story
i'd just say i didn't love that element
of this whole move this this to be four
feels like the first time where they're
just like toys aren't going to care
anymore about whether humans hear them
or know they're
like he used to be very strict like any
human in the immediate proximity you go
limp and you're
dead and like nothing no matter what
they do
they could burn a hole in your face and
you're not allowed to like react at
all right and now in this one
it's like they hear you but it could be
a person outside it's okay and it's like
wait a minute
if you could just interact with the
human world this whole time like
again it brings up this uncomfortable
tension of like well then who's forcing
them to be quiet like why aren't they
just like
hey i'm a toy i'm real and i exist screw
you man
you know like they they kill the ones
that do that um
and also it shows you that toy loyalty
extends only as far as the child like
the parents their sol
man they can go to jail go to hell like
we're we're sticking with the with the
four-year-old
on some level it's it's play like what
what bonds the kids of the toys is play
and if you don't play with them they do
not care about you at all you don't
exist
you're dead to us it's true that's what
what he has to explain to fork you like
your body's trash and that's what makes
it make sense to him
yeah all right keep playing
masters if it furthers they're selfish
aims dad's totally going to jail
because when one kid and her dumb fork
are separated woody's got to get to
kindergarten get to forky get back to
the family get away from the antique
store get away from this other kid get
back to the antique store get the key to
the cabinet get to the cabinet get away
from the cat get to forky get back to
bonnie get back to gaby get to the
carousel get back to bonnie wait hold
that thought get gabby to a straight
child now get back to bonnie hold that
thought get back to beau and live
happily ever after
look there was no good reason to make
another one of these but if the story
moves fast enough you might not even
notice and
darn it how do they manage to make me
cry again my childhood died three toy
stories ago
so prepare to leave unless it is
uh boots riley or something completely
different i do hope this is the last toy
story because
all in all after everything is said and
done like they did end it well
they did give you like some finality and
a send-off
and you know i assume woody and bo live
happily ever after
until one kid steps on her and she
shatters into
like a thousand shards i i feel like the
way to do it
if you must keep the franchise going if
you absolutely must
i think uh it it it shouldn't be this
narrative anymore so like we got to get
away from woody i mean i'm sure they'd
be delighted to not have to pay tom
hanks every time
regardless uh i don't think we need to
do woody and buzz and bonnie and
and and this room full of toys but i
also think
it would be pretty easy to keep this
going with just
it's the same world the toys play by the
same rules but you just
here's a new room full of toys here's a
new premise involving toys like
you could keep this go like forky could
be his
own movie with a different character
advising him and like
it didn't need to be this he's got his
own so i think that there is a way
forward
for disney i mean just like what they're
doing with uh the monsters inc
tv spin-off where it's going to be it's
set within the company monsters inc
but it's not mike wazowski and sully and
their crew it's like different people
who work there
and i think pixar's got a lot of room
that they could do they could do that
with like
most of their worlds like i could see a
it's set at the aquarium from finding
dory but you don't need nemo and dory in
it
as well yeah right it's just the
shutters who build
uh who build gundams um meticulously
painted gundams
love it it could be joan is warhammer uh
figurines coming to life at night
um i love oh honestly like that i do
think like because we were talking about
i think somebody pitched this as a movie
fight one time and it wasn't me so if
this was you
well done on your movie fight premise i
remembered it but there was somebody who
was like it's
it's set in an office and all of the
guys knick-knacks from his cubicle
are the toys that come to life and
they've got to like
save his job or something and it's like
in a workplace toy story and like i
think that could totally work like
do it for disney plus why not okay well
you're right time march is on toy more
toy stories are inevitable
but i agree with you that this narrative
of these toys coming to terms with their
toy mortality or whatever like this
feels done to me
i don't feel the need to rejoin woody
and beau on the road
or whatever that that's good we're good
okay good
agreed okay keep going there we are so
prepare to lose yourself in an adventure
that looks even more dazzling than the
others
even though randy newman clearly phoned
it in this time
in a field that's not interested in your
dumb logical questions about how this
world works
how am i alive
i don't know but really wants to explore
whether toys should prefer rough play
with a string of different
children or stick to the stable gentle
caress of a single child with whom they
share a deep and lifelong bond
okay why does it sound like i'm
describing fifty shades of grey now way
to make it weird movie
combat carl's getting played with
[Music]
story retire kitsch karl marx
communist manifesto
i know that this one like all things are
forgotten into the ether
in like 48 hours but this is just
verbatim something that tim
allen uh shared on his twitter his karl
marx
i don't know what my favorite i don't
know what my favorite part of this whole
thing is
uh misspelling karl marx obviously a
plus
fantastic suggesting the
the wikipedia version of the communist
manifesto i mean it is just a manifesto
you could just read it you don't need to
it's not very digesting it's just
this was almost definitely a google
search that he typed into twitter
accidentally and then tried to like own
right i mean we all agree on that right
i think it had to be like oh god i'm
trying to i'm trying to fight a lib
online
let me see what uh
what was that there's problems with that
communist manifesto what was he on about
that karl marx
and then he clicked on uh uh
controversies
on on the on the wikipedia entry i'm
gonna scroll down here
uh rebuttals oh a lot a lot of these a
lot of these lots to work with lots to
work with
i would love if uh if uh tim allen in in
wikipedia in the communist manifesto
just became like a maoist
it's like seize the means of production
wait a minute so i should have owned all
those tools myself this changes
everything
two men of the world unite
that's another good movie all right keep
going yeah
karl marx communist manifesto wikipedia
i'm in cutlery now mother twee and peel
bows before bros police cutality
dolly d'arco keanu revs
party of pies and beloved character
actors getting paid to only save woody
and buzz
buzzing woody woody woody
woody woody woody
what would he do child's play
so when boopy a lamp looks at these
chandeliers does she think they're like
her cousins or something
i mean yeah we could have put a thousand
existential questions uh
in there i mean yeah we had a we had a
few different ones dolly is incredible
that's bonnie hunt as the little felt
doll character who says like
three things in this whole movie like
yeah such a yeah you gotta get she
started like eight tv shows there were
some
messed up things i did not put in here
uh
one was what happens when people make
their toys kiss each other that's really
messed up
because they're alive and they have to
think about that no choice they have
like
significant others like they have
relationships
so you're making them cheat on one
another i didn't even think about that
yeah totally and then uh yeah that joke
we don't even need to talk about that
joke that's uh
that wasn't just too too hot for the
outtakes even too hot even for
commentary
even for commentaries um but i like that
the uh the 50 shades
the 50 shades thing did did get in there
because there's a lot
this this movie in particular versus
three because three and four
i'm just gonna go for it they uh they're
they change
the narrative because three is like a
toy's worst nightmare would be
you're in a daycare and like all these
kids are gonna come in and it's like
rough play all day and they don't
they're you're not their toy so they're
not protective of you
they're just slamming you around and i
was like okay i accept that as a premise
but then four is like the best thing for
a toy ever would just be to be on a
playground man you're free any kid comes
it's like isn't that exactly what so
you've said some toys are into that
right some toys like toys like group
play and some toys are more monogamous
yeah like
i don't want to think about the
ramifications of this in terms of the
toy story series so yeah some toys like
rough play and some toys prefer the
gentle caress of a
child with whom they formed a meaningful
bond and
they've groomed this child you see and
said
it couldn't be simply
this is troubling if you guys haven't
turned it off in disgust yet
uh now's the time to thank you for
watching so click like click subscribe
hit that bell so you can uh uh find out
every time we're on and having
discussions much like this one so you
get what you pay for
like this one let's also this friday
there's another
fandom five trivia contest uh if you're
a
console head if you know your xbox and
your playstations you can answer
questions about that and win
real money i believe up to 650 dollars
which will get you
a ps5 and some games um you uh
uh you sign up one game one game
probably one game
plus tax yeah maybe a half a day you'll
be all right it'd be fine
you get 80 of that miles morales game
so uh if you know about that sign up and
play this friday also it's november
and we're uh supporting um
stack up which is veterans organization
that brings veterans and civilians
together
through a shared love of the gaming um
it assists veterans and civilians to
assist in crisis intervention suicide
prevention issues concerning mental
health
through gaming and community uh november
is their call to arms
and their biggest fundraising push so
check out stackup.org
for more information um with that said
let's roll on into some deleted scenes
see what didn't make it in
and where even the celebrity cameos are
quietly heartbreaking
remember when she played house i liked
house those were the days
comeback carl's getting played with oh
come on
someone give combat carla's high five he
wants it so bad
[Music]
how the west was done cowboys on the
side
spaceman still astronaut really in this
one
a tool man astroglide
next to last man standing new sport
dolls
trash bandicoot p.s i love utensil
poochie prize and dolls plushed away
sheeple fun breakable molly's gangs
the epancipation of mini tiny goon
adventures
small cops are bastards let's weak cops
brahms the girl puppet master
goosebumps the daredevils advocate
cheesy rider john trick the gold horns
and read for phil they're all toys
oh trash you're just like me
trash the maybe litters club
the lost toys the plastics
game of chaperones
yeah it's a tough one to uh uh to do the
maybe litters club
i thought the maybe litters club was it
man when i wrote that one i was like
hell yeah yeah it's going right in the
trailer you're right because it was it
did have a lot to do about trash
it's yeah well it's right because it's
the babysitter club but also maybe he's
he says he's litter i don't know
sometimes so much of this one
i should have picked it sometimes you
hit on the perfect pun and you're just
like well that's the perfect pun
but but sometimes i agree the perfect
pun is not necessarily the joke that
works the best in that spot it's just
the best
part because i also think new spork
dolls
for forkey is a really good pun but not
it like it
doesn't work perfectly for an honest did
you know there are actual like
pun professional pun competitions and
they like throw out a category and you
have to fire off as many
on theme puns as possible yeah see that
kind of sounds annoying
i mean i just think you could crush it
i probably would do okay yeah i like our
version of it where you try to come up
with puns but then a lot of the time
better than the pun is just like the
dumb joke like i like that about honest
trailers that sometimes a dumb joke is
even better
than a really perfectly crafted well
done
big fun name like like karl marx
communist manifesto wikipedia makes me
laugh in this more than any of the puns
i read
there you go um that's it from us so
what did
y'all have to say about it uh johannes
stromer
asks well like we kind of covered this
what's your ultimate pitch for toy story
i do think some type of toy revolution
would be
um a fun like lean into the fact that
like they're sentient and maybe this
isn't a good deal for some of the toys
maybe not all of them want to be
property um i i like uh
horror movie it's a nerd and he's gonna
pack up and get rid of all of his like
room full of man cave full of
funkos and nerdy toys from a whole
lifetime of collecting
and they decide they don't want to get
sold and have an uprising it's like a
horror film
now they're going to like kidnap him and
keep him in his house so he can't sell
them
and it's like ready player one but a
horror film in this one nerds apart
yeah okay yeah i like that too
um levetto writes who's your favorite
canadian besides keanu
favorite canadian i mean i mean you
gotta tip the hat
recently departed great uh tv host
alex trebek i think sure tip of our hat
to one of the legends of canada
uh canada is like way over indexed as
far as like great comedians go
like right i was going to say sctv is
like a treasure trove you got your rick
moranises your john candies
uh your eugene levy your entire levee
family the entire level family captain
o'hara yeah
you're katherine o'hara's exactly i mean
it's not almost short i think it's right
there
martin shortest canadian yeah jim
carrey's fox
mike myers canadian nor mcdonald's
canadian yeah
like so many every good 90s comedian is
canadian so thank you canada
we appreciate it great canadian
entertainers for yeah
i'll throw in my answer the band sum 41.
i do have one more how dare you
also the the great canadian horror
auteur uh david cronenberg
i also got it through corona yeah nice
on my pile of favorite canadians
uh enough canada fluffing uh brent
dreyer writes what are your guys own
worst
slash least necessary fourth films that
he says that ended a franchise that's
kind of tough i don't know
how many but ended up worse but once
they get to four they usually
keep going uh like i'm sure that
whatever the fourth terminator was was
bad whether that was um
it wasn't genesis it was uh the the live
the one with christian bale right
salvation
salvation yeah that was that was a
stinker but they kept going that's the
one that
that actually jumps forward into the
future war
i was gonna say uh i don't love
halloween for i feel like bringing back
michael myers was the way to go but it
i don't like the direction and like four
five and six that whole trilogy i don't
think it's really very good so i'm
inclined to say that kind of brought the
series back but on a
on a weak footing yeah um
there aren't many that had four i'm just
looking at
are we considering the phantom menace
the fourth
star wars yeah like but once that
literally ended on number four like i'm
looking at a thing it's like i don't
think that
it's the spirit of it they made four
bloodsports i mean i'm going to watch
all of them but i can't imagine
bloodsport 4 the dark
kumite was as good as the first three
no probably not i mean i don't even know
if i've seen bloodsport
two they made four cutting edge movies
oh my god
wow where was there to go for american
tale movies
the uh that kept going after five went
rest
it didn't end the franchise but some
people are saying terminator salvation
yeah oh uh uh if you i think this counts
if you consider
the burton schumacher batman series
series that batman and robin is a pretty
bad
entry for that didn't kill off that
version of batman
oh oh here's the good one crystal skull
i mean that's that's like well but they
are they are coming back for part five
man so
who knows but yes i agree there you go
there's your answer yeah um uh
final thing and this is a again thank
you to our sponsor candy crush we love
sponsors on this show that's awesome
thank you for sponsoring
uh a fun game i can actually
put my name on that and be like i feel
good telling you to download candy crush
um but they uh uh we should discuss um
the shows or movies that had the best
toys when you were playing them what
were what were your favorite uh
movie and tv tie-in toys that maybe or
maybe not uh came to life
uh while you weren't there had rich
emotional lives that you ignored as a
child
uh i i mean i played with a lot of like
uh the
standard like 80s like i'm really dating
myself
when i was a kid but like star wars toys
and transformers
and gi joes i i was really into
he-man masters of the universe toys when
that film came out
so i wasn't like the toy tie-in with the
film
because i didn't like the movie but i
already was a big he-man fan i'm trying
to think of toys that actually
tied into movies that i would i mean i
was
oh i was so specialized oh ghostbusters
yeah those are with the whole set
the like the with the fire pole and
stuff like that yes i had a lot of i had
a lot of ghostbusters toys and that
both real like the movie ghostbusters
but also that animated the real
ghostbusters
saturday morning cartoon series i really
like yeah so i had a lot of that stuff
like their slimer and that ecto one
yeah they had like the whole firehouse
set
i mean i was a turtles kid through and
through i had uh
i had the main turtles i had slash i had
um
you know casey jones uh i had the my
brother had the blimp but he broke it
um that was lame and uh and then the uh
the van gun that shot pizzas
uh those are definitely my favorite toys
as a kid but the thing is like
if they came to life at night they would
just reenact ninja turtles i guess
they would just have to be in a s i mean
they would have been ninja turtles so
they would have had to
i do remember that and i it was not my i
was a really big fan of the movie
i don't know if i played with the toys a
lot i think i was probably aging out of
toy
range at this point but also i had a
bunch of willow toys
there was like a whole tie-in willa so
you could get the castle and
mad morgan yeah the evil the evil wicked
queen
and the skull the guys got the big skull
helmet
on yeah uh so i had a bunch of those
figures as well
at some point that's fun all right well
uh that's it for this week you guys
thanks for watching uh really
appreciate your support and um come back
next week where we will be
talking about something that's hmm
it's a new movie that feels old it felt
old to me
so um you be the judge of that
thanks again to candy crush for the
sponsorship and we'll see you next week
bye bye this episode is sponsored by
google play
download candy crush saga and discover
more on google play now
[Music]
you